public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
jean-luc mélenchon candidat bien sûr
l'élection présidentielle est l'invité
de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir bonsoir
michel et merci d'être avec nous à ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec la fp
avec les échos et radio classique alors
comme chaque semaine trois grandes
parties trois grandes questions pour
vous d'abord au nom du peuple point
d'interrogation mais le créneau est
désormais occupé également par nicolas
sarkozy qui n'a que ce mot à la bouche
alors jean francis pécresse le directeur
de la rédaction de radio classique sera
le premier à vous interroger dans un
instant ensuite stéphanie le rouge de la
fp vous demandera quel visage aurait
votre france insoumise si vous
l'emportez enfin votre vote
révolutionnaire ouvre-t-il en fait la
route à la droite voire à l'extrême
droite au chaos selon l'accusation du
ministre jean marie le guen qui était
notre invité ici même la semaine
dernière bien voulu répondre et et c'est
mickaël szames est ce qui nous nature en
a pas mieux à faire qu'à répondent à de
telles sottises avait vous répondrais
oui d'accord mais qu'elle aimait ce qui
sera là pour la troisième partie
d'émission a également d'autres
questions pour vous mais d'abord jean
luc mélenchon une question d'actualité
bien sûr la crise entre la france et la
russie avec vladimir poutine qui a
décidé d'annuler finalement sa venue à
paris
est-ce que vous soutenez françois
hollande dans son bras de fer pour faire
avancer la paix dit il
non pas du tout on ne fait rien avancer
du tout c'est une je désapprouve
absolument ce qu'il est en train de
faire qui est totalement contraire aux
intérêts de la france
d'abord envoyé jean marc ayrault porter
une lettre d'invitation monsieur poutine
pour ensuite dire qu'on ne sait pas si
on va le recevoir pour terminer les
russes dans une attitude plutôt
raisonnable pour éviter des incidents
qui ensuite nous entraîner dans une
escalade de mes aventures diplomatique
qui ne sont pas bonnes pour le pays
disent que il reporte la visite
l'attitude de françois hollande est
absolument insupportable nous sommes
totalement alignée sur les états unis
d'amérique nous courons devant et c'est
une attitude qu'il n'est pas du tout
conforme aux intérêts de la france qui
n'a qu'un préalable je le répète faire
avancer la paix hal est notamment mais
c'est pas cette manière là qu'on fait
avancer la paix en quoi est ce que le
fait de provoquer des incidents
diplomatiques de cette nature fait
avancer la paix veut provoquer une
discussion sérieuse exclusivement sur la
syrie ce bon que ça n'est pas sérieux
surtout en menaçant monsieur poutine de
l'envoyer au tribunal pénal
international enfin qui est françois
hollande
à part la risée de l'univers à peine
était-il élus qu'il a accepté que les
nord-américains installe des bases de
missiles antimissiles soi disant pour
parer les missiles que l'iran était
censé vouloir nous tirer dessus
voici que entre temps il s'est
réconcilié avec l'iran mais que les
bases de missiles s'y trouvent et par
conséquent la russie est menacée vous
voyez bien que nous sommes en train
d'aller progressivement à une situation
de guerre alors ouvrons très réussie je
pouvais dire que l'attitude de françois
hollande participe de l' escalade qui
conduit à la confrontation avec la
russie quant à lui françois hollande ne
cesse de dire des choses qui n'ont pas
de sens
un temps poutine était un ennemi puis un
jour il reprend mon vocabulaire et il
dit la russie n'est pas un ennemi mais
un partenaire le surlendemain il a
encore changé d'attitude et de
vocabulaire
tout ça rend la france illisible
inefficace et absent en des conditions
de règlement du conflit en syrie on ira
rêve ou la vie d'il ya un instant vous
contestez par ailleurs
lente et de la france d'engager une
action devant la cour pénale
internationale pour les crimes de guerre
commis par la russie avec avec ses
avions qui bombardent aujourd'hui encore
à alep faisant de nombreuses victimes
civiles est ce que vous contestez la
notion de crimes de guerre imputés à mes
jeux à la russie tout ça ce sont des
bavardages
il y à une guerre c'est une réalité
terriblement dur mis d'accord que jean
michel grossiord nous allons commencer
par dire que nous n'aimons pas les
bombardements ni vous ni moi
d'ailleurs nous ne les avons jamais aimé
ni quand on détruisait lorient brest le
havre caen pour essayer de tuer la
poignée de nazis qui se trouvaient là et
donc n'avons jamais mais les beautés de
la guerre dans votre livre vous dites la
guerre est toujours sales et l'anglais
aujourd'hui plus que jamais ni plus ni
moins l ess à l'aller horrible à les
abominables les bombardements des
saoudiens au yémen sont abominables
les bombardements sur les civils quels
qu'ils soient sont abominablement
monsieur gros sur les bombardements vous
voulez voir de ma bouche sortir le mot
russe pour que ça rentre dans le
vocabulaire ambiant alors les
bombardements en général sont
condamnables monsieur jean michel
grossiord arrêté avec la politique de
disneyland
il y à une guerre et les deux parties
essayent de la gagner je verrais bien la
tête et les questions que vous poserez à
vos invités
d'ici quelques jours quand commenceront
les bombardements sur mossoul
vous les trouverez divin parce que
libérateur vous savez qu'il ya des
français qui sont engagés là bas vous
savez que l'artillerie c'est les
français qui l'organisent
et à ce moment là qu'est ce qu'on dira
évidemment on fera pas de reproche à nos
soldats qui obéissent et qu'il regarde
mon jeu demandera quelle il semble me
saouler l'est le fief du groupe etat
islamique on parle aujourd'hui de
bombardements qui affectent la
population civile particulièrement
d'accord avec mme soullie a pas de
civils
bien sûr bien alors à l'aide de quoi
parlons nous allez dites le dites le
nous parlons de la zone s dahleb qui est
tenu par qui parti jean michel grossiord
des modérés des modérés d'al-qaïda qui
ont assassiné
les rédacteurs de charlie hebdo vous
tenez à tout prix à trier entre je vous
pose des questions convergents mais
voyez pas cette notion de rebelles
acceptable rien pour l'occident par look
si la guerre et la guerre elle est
abominable il faut l'arrêter et pour
cela il faut faire une coalition
universel c'est-à-dire qui regroupe
absolument toutes les parties prenantes
au conflit pour
d'abord en finir avec les forces armées
des milices de l'islamisme politique
puisque c'est ce que nous combattons là
bas et deuxièmement il faut mettre sur
la table les vrais problèmes de cette
guerre qui n'ont rien à voir avec la
religion qui sont les frontières des
quatre états concernés par la situation
des kurdes et le passage des oléoducs et
des gazoducs
on ne veut pas parler de ça de temps à
autre il y à des ouvertures dans le ciel
et on peut un peu parlé des problèmes de
fond vous n'arrêtez pas une guerre si
vous n'êtes pas d'accord pour traiter
des problèmes qui l'ont déclare donc il
faut en parler il faut accueillir
vladimir poutine ait accepté de le voir
à ces conditions où il faut imposer
comme le fait aujourd'hui françois
hollande mais ça n'a pas de sens
monsieur jean michel grossiord vous
voulez poser des conditions à quelqu'un
avec qui vous voulez discuter vous
voulez discuter avec lui à condition
qu'ils soient d'accord avec vous c'est
ça une discussion je comprends que sur
un plateau ça soit la règle il faut être
d'accord avec le joueur avancer la paix
dans la vie faire avancer la paix ça
nécessite qu'on s'en donne les moyens
et pour ça il faut que la france
elle-même cesse d'être le petit
répétiteur des états unis d'amérique
si nous étions indépendants nous serions
en situation de faire avancer nos idées
nos propositions notamment celle d'un
cessez-le-feu général un cessez le feu
que les nord américains ne violerait pas
cette vous dit françois hollande et le
perroquet
des états unis mais j'ai par exemple
dirigé par les deux périodes mais si les
états unis sont totalement silencieux
vous avez vu dans la phase actuelle il
n'existe pas a pratiquement avant ça
c'est le point de vue de cet homme de
télé réunion mais la question justement
les américains sont quand même un nom
les américains sont présents ils
manipulent leurs pions il bombarde là où
il estime nécessaire de le faire ils
n'ont rien fait pendant des mois tout en
faisant semblant de s'agiter contre des
ch et maintenant chacun essaye d'occuper
le plus de territoire possible mais vous
verrez bientôt que les russes vont
s'entendre avec les turcs qui jusque là
étaient les alliés des nord-américains
et faisait transiter le pétrole
clandestins de dèche et maintenant ils
n'ont s'entendre ensemble pour le tracé
du gazoduc à ce moment là la guerre va
ralentir mais néanmoins monsieur jean
michel grossi en scène ce jour arrivera
quand ce jour arrivera vous ne me
poserait plus la question de savoir si
j'approuve l'un ou l'autre et vous ferez
comme tous les autres d'où vous tirez
pendant qu'on massacrera les kurdes
ce qu'on est déjà en train de faire
parce qu'il dérange tout le monde
dernière monsieur michel grossiord les
situations complexes ne peuvent hélas
pas rentrer dans les formats de télé à
travers on a essayé quand même si vous
avez fait valoir votre point de vue je
crois que c'était clair tous les gars
vous aviez déclaré en février dernier je
pense que vladimir poutine va régler le
problème en syrie
vous le pensez toujours alors attendez
monsieur michel grossiord vous voyez ça
c'est un procédé de journalisme je peux
répondre non alors je réponds mais cette
phrase elle est à l'intérieur d'une
émission je venais on venait de me
demander comme vous rire ce qu'on fait
maintenant concrètement il y avait des
bombardements que bombarder les russes à
ce moment là non mais je vous pose la
cua que vous n'en savez rien et vous
lisez votre papier
il s'agit ont bombardé à l'époque les
convois de pétrole clandestins qui
allait de syrie en turquie et les russes
bombardé ça et c'est dans ce cas que
j'ai dit je pense qu'ils vont faire le
travail et maintenant je vais vous dire
autre chose
je n'ai aucune tendresse pour les
islamistes qui se trouvent dans alep est
parce que c'est eux qui ont assassiné et
journaliste français et par conséquent
je ne veux pas entrer dans cette logique
simpliste où il faudrait prouver les
bombardements d un désapprouvé ceux des
autres non je veux la paix et je vous
redis je vous
redis solennellement il y à un risque de
guerre généralisée en europe en neurones
roms en europe aussi car les bases quand
ça les états unis d'amérique en pologne
et les troupes qu'il déploie sur le
terrain avec l'accord des français sont
une provocation antirusse qui n'ont
aucun intérêt stratégique et sont
nuisibles aux intérêts de la france
si vous voulez vous battre pour la paix
il faut être indépendant voilà ce que
moi je défends dans cette campagne
présidentielle et peu me chaut que les
gens changent d'avis tous les jours moi
je ne change pas d'avis tous les jours
voilà qui est dit sur cette crise
diplomatique
donc on poursuit maintenant avec jean
francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique
l'épreuve de vérité mais critique ici et
musicaux bonsoir
alors votre occupation et vos questions
à jean luc mélenchon alors au nom du
peuple puisque vous êtes vous voulez le
porte parole du peuple qu'est ce que
vous feriez pour que les forces de l'anp
puisse intervenir dans les zones
populaires sans être agressé de manière
parfois extrêmement violente comme on
l'a vu il ya quelques jours à la grande
borne à côté d'eux les riches at il que
vous connaissez bien vers l'éolien
fédérer lui les sacrements et bien sûr
alors d'abord deux choses au nom du
peuple le slogan de madame le pen donc
si vous voulez bien on utilisera un
autre repère parce que sinon on pourrait
créer la confusion chez ceux qui nous
écoutent
premièrement deuxième enjeu est ce qu'il
ya un peu je ne prétends pas représenter
le peuvent vous m'aurez mal compris
j'essaye de le représenter le peuple
existe indépendamment de ce qui porte sa
parole ce qui est nouveau c'est que
maintenant nombre croissant de gens
acceptent de reconnaître qu'il y à un
peuple qui est acteur de l'histoire
auparavant les ans ne reconnaissait que
les prolétaires et les autres leurs amis
point des électeurs maintenant on
commence à comprendre qu'il y à un
peuple c'est à dire un acteur nouveau
dans l'histoire qui s'est manifestée
sous tous les horizons qui auparavant
n'existait pas maintenant parlons des
forces de l'ordre ce que nous avons eues
à viry monsieur doit être nommé par son
nom c'est à dire une tentative de
meurtre c'est une tentative de meurtre
par image aux yeux de sauvageons pardon
c'est un môme alsace et l'espoir c'est
un mot malheureux ça c'est l'espoir d'un
certain nombre de gens que l'on puisse
une nouvelle fois montré du doigt une
population d'abord une population et
ensuite pourquoi pas une religion tu
vends l'habitude qui est dorénavant pris
dans ce pays non il s'agit d'une
tentative de meurtre par des criminels
qui ont des trafics qu'il faut combattre
jusqu'au bout et qui veulent empêcher
l'installation d'une caméra qui
viendrait les contrarier par conséquent
nous avons affaire à un délit de droit
commun est clairement et fermement
nous devons au contraire bien tout faire
pour montrer qu'il s'agit de criminels
et que c'est pas une attitude de
sauvageons ou je ne sais quoi
d'accord ce ne sont pas des sauvageons
ce sont des trafiquants et des criminels
et qui ont essayé d'assassiner des gens
qui sont en l'occurrence en défense et
par surprise en leur jetant des
cocktails molotov dans la voiture il est
clair que de telles une telle attitude
doit être réprimé il n'y a pas d'autre
mot a utilisé peut réprimer alors après
faut raison garder raison garder
c'est faire attention à ne pas leur
permettre de se cacher derrière une
autre population qui n'en peut mais qui
n'en peut mais pas c'est pas elle qui a
choisi de vivre dans des conditions
pareilles
avec de tels gens à proximité des camps
le premier se dit qu'il n'ya pas de zone
de non droit en va en france vous êtes
d'accord
bon parce que la zone de non droit c'est
devenu l'argument pour justifier tout et
n'importe quoi il ya des endroits où la
loi n'avance plus où elle est tenue à
distance parce que il ya plus de
policiers il ya plus de bureaux de poste
il ya plus de 2 y'a plus rien et les
gens sont abandonnés livrés à eux mêmes
et par conséquent comme toujours dans
les sociétés humaines les plus forts
tiennent le terrain et là ce sont des
criminels
est-ce qu'il ya quand même en france
est-ce que vous reconnaissez qu'il ya
des territoires abandonnés de la
république où les forces de l'ordre de
jeu pourquoi utilisez-vous un mot vous
comme reconnaissez vous croyez que je
n'ai jamais nié parce que maintenant
mais je le vis j'étais déjà conseiller
général dans une banlieue que vous étiez
encore à l'école de journalistes donc je
sais très bien je sais très bien ce que
c'est que tout ça l'état a abandonné les
populations et maintenant voici qu'il
leur jette à la figure son propre
abandon
là où l'on a fermé les postes là où on a
fermé le commissariat de police là où on
enferme et l'antenne de sanitaires on
vient dire aujourd'hui comment ça se
fait en plus vous osez une pas être
content et alors feriez et qui souffre
et parce que vous êtes dans la
dénonciation vous utilisez des mots très
forts mais qu'est ce que vous feriez
vous à la place du
du gouvernement la sécurité pour la
sécurité bien sûr que vous êtes déjà
d'accord pour dire qu'il ya un problème
évidemment que c'est un problème quand
bon très bien à votre independent
attaques des marchés
alors à votre avis comment peut-on
régler le problème du crime prenant la
chose rationnellement du crime organisé
comment le règle tant en pourchassant
les criminels donc il faut pour ça du
personnel c'est l'arrêt pris soin fasse
autre chose que de protéger une caméra à
deux dans une voiture d'accord quand y'a
plus rien dans le quartier c'est ce que
demandent les syndicats de police en
raison et la population demandent une
protection qui est dû à n'importe qui
dans ce pays vous devez pouvoir vous
sentir protégé parole pas par des par la
police de même que vous pouvez vous
sentir protégé par votre école parce que
vous apprenez vos enfants sont élevés et
soigné donc monsieur ma réponse est la
suivante que faut-il faire petit à le
contraire de ce que fait hollande est le
contraire de ce que veut faire sarkozy
est le contraire de ce que veut faire
juppé bien sûr tous veulent supprimer
des postes de fonctionnaires
trois cent mille a dit monsieur sarkozy
six cent mille a dit moussa dans la
police dit on atteint le mât dans la
police alors est ce qu'on entend dans
l'éducation nationale dans l'éducation
de ruines dans l'éducation révision donc
il ya trop d'instituteur et on apprend
que l'enseignant dans la police non mais
attendez un instant on reste sur le son
mais on en reste pas on ira où je veux
si vous voulez bien mais c'est quand
même moi qui réponds oui
alors si vous voulez qu'on parle de la
police la police et l'actualité oui mais
je vous suis en train de vous répondre
on ne peut pas faire de police en
policier voilà ce que je vous réponds
comme ça mais dans le bon sens qu'il
soit donné un poste donc si vous voulez
supprimer de postes supplémentaires
vous le serez bientôt car nous allons
faire un point sur la sécurité et vous
même vous rendez compte de l'absurdité
de notre question non à branchement on
est bien content sinon vous ne la
poseriez par manuel valls annonce
aujourd'hui que les véhicules dans ces
quartiers sensibles auront un dispositif
anti caillassage est ce que c'est une
bonne mesure est ce que ça va dans le
bon sens les syndicats de policiers
disent que ça va plutôt dans le bon sens
que c'est insuffisant mais que ça va
dans le bon sens mais écoutez
franchement vous croyez que c'est une
discussion qui vaut la peine d'être mené
alors nous sommes d'accord pressez anti
caillassage également je fais une
recommandation mettez de l'essence dans
le véhicule
oubliez de dire une chose s'ils ont des
armes si possible des munitions mais il
faut pas les utiliser dans n'importe
quelle circonstance
nous sommes en train d'enfoncer des
portes ouvertes qui permettent de
tourner autour du problème sans jamais
le régler mesdames messieurs l'élection
de 2017 a pour objet la question
suivante qu'est-ce qui gouverne la
société le marché est ce que l'état doit
être expulsé de partout c'est vous qui
part je peux pas vous pardon mais c'est
ce qu'ils ont voulu à tout prix
n'est ce pas que l'état disparaissent de
partout on a dit qu'il était énorme
qu'il était ventripotent on l'a traité
diplodocus de tous les noms et bien
maintenant vous êtes tous en train de
pleurer sur les conséquences des
décisions qui ont été prises il faut que
l'état revienne dans ce pays car la
france s'est construite autour de son
état et si vous voulez avoir des
fonctionnaires de police qui n'est plus
peur et qui donc ne se comporte pas
comme des gens qui ont peur il faut
qu'ils puissent exercer leur métier dans
des conditions normales mais ce n'est
pas la police qui maintient l'ordre
je vous le redis c'est la société qui le
maintient elle même parce qu'elle est en
ordre
et c'est maintenant notre consoeur
stéphanie le rouge de la lfp qui vient
pour la suite
l'épreuve de vérité avec l'iphone
donc bon soir stéphane richard soit
votre question à jean luc mélenchon et
bien donc nous allons nous pencher sur
le visage de cette france insoumise donc
vous réunissez
votre convention
ce week end avec notamment six cent
cinquante personnes qui ont été tirés au
sort ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
ce choix qui est assez merci de
commencer par là c'est à dire le
mouvement lui même je sais que c'était
un objet nouveau
c'est donc un prototype que nous allons
voir ce dimanche il y aura donc des
choses imparfaite je le dis parce que je
suis un peu angoissé savoir si nous
allons réussir tout ce que nous
entreprenons
nous avons tiré au sort les deux tiers
de la convention si je me trompe pas 650
sur le millier qui va y avoir parmi les
signataires il y en a cent trente cinq
mille de la france insoumis c'est à dire
des personnes qui ont décidé de donner
leur appui à ma candidature
pourquoi vous me tirer au sort pas parce
que c'est plus démocratique de tir ça
c'est un débat qui est très ouvert mais
parce que nous ne voulions pas
d'élection car élections voudrait dire
que nous deviendrions à partie avec des
plateformes des tendances des textes
d'orientation et des gens se présentant
à cette convention au nom d'une chose ou
non d'une autre en réalité la convention
son objet est réglé puisque le programme
amy a été mis en discussion a été
élaboré pendant sept mois par des
contributions individuelles sur la base
du programme l'humain d'abord que
j'avais déposé il y a eu des auditions
il y en a eu 16 ou 17 heures hier soir
j'ai encore participer à la 18e sur les
logiciels libres
bref et ensuite les organisations
politiques qui apportent leur soutien à
ma candidature en elle-même t leur
proposition de tout ça nous avons tiré
un texte qui lui même est en ce moment
en cours de vote à l'intérieur des cent
trente sept mille votants il n'a pas lu
tirés au sort et nous allons donc faire
quelque chose que personne n'a jamais
fait tirer au sort une convention des
gens viennent ils participent à un débat
d'abord il exactement de cette
convention parce qu'on ne comprend pas
bien donc le diagnostic pour vous il est
derrière vous le programme
le mans s'est fait également qu'est ce
que tu vas faire là d'abord nous allons
dans les vous m'interrogez sur les
choses que nous allons factuellement
faire d'abord nous allons comment dire
transmettre le document c'est un acte
que je ne pouvais pas faire de moi même
j'ai pensé qu'il fallait le faire du
mouvement présentation du programme en
fait oui nous allons le présenter
il y aura encore des modifications
j'imagine de dernière minute il y aura
un classement des priorités qui va être
fait par les participants et il y aura
quelque chose qui me paraît très
important très important c'est le
donnait à voir
nous avons commencé à le faire avec le
défilé de la france insoumise le 5 juin
dernier à stalingrad
c'est le moment où l'on donne à la
parole à ceux qui ne l'ont jamais par
exemple des syndicalistes par exemple
des lanceurs dallaire par exemple des
gens qui dans la vie quotidienne
incarnent des choses dont vous n'avez
pas idée moi non plus parce que je ne le
vis pas mais qui sont les problèmes de
la vie de tous les jours tous les cas
officiellement le pcf
oui bien sûr dix membres le parti
communiste français ne pas m'en bien sûr
veux pas l'être ne veut pas et dit
aujourd'hui ne se prononcer que pour un
programme est pas un candidat donc pas
pour vous jean luc mélenchon est encore
possible d'imaginer un rassemblement
ce manifestement de la fête de
l'humanité pierre laurent avait dit
qu'il souhaitait vous rencontrer pour
évoquer un certain nombre de sujets qui
vous divise
il ya notamment la question des
travailleurs détachés de la banque de la
france d'où on apprenait l'union
européenne il ya également la question
des gauches irréconciliables donc plus
une question stratégique
vous n'avez pas souhaité cette rencontre
pourquoi déjà et ce qu'elle peut avoir
lieu
non ils continuent d'appeler oui très
bien les communistes participe par
milliers à la france insoumis je le
répète ce n'est pas un parti il n'y a
pas besoin d'abandonner son parti pour
militer à la france insoumise donc des
communistes des élus communistes
parraine ma candidature et il y en aura
d'ici peu davantage encore on en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure mais donc
voyons la méthode ce que dit pierre
laurent est toujours très intéressant et
je n'écoute avec toujours beaucoup
d'intérêt par exemple il a décidé que
tous les communistes candidats aux
législatives seraient investis en
septembre il l'a fait il a dit qu'il ne
veut pas d'accord national qu'il
qualifie de tripatouillage met d'accord
au cas par cas et bien parfait nous
ferons des accords au cas par cas la
france insoumise aura des candidats
partout
je répète la france insoumise aura des
candidats aux législatives dans les 577
circonscriptions candidature mais c'est
où
nous verrons cela fera je leur à des
candidats oui pas très bien il y aura
des candidats communistes france
insoumise
c'est ce que je peux dire quant au reste
je n'en sais rien car ce que dit pierre
laurent est intéressant mais je voudrais
montrer si vous le permettez un instant
la limite de qui parle-t-il
les socialistes sont engagés dans une
primaire at il entendu dire que l'un
quelconque des candidats à cette
primaire a l'intention de venir faire
une candidature commune hors du ps avec
nous non at il entendu un seul candidat
vert à la primaire dire qu'il veut faire
une candidature commune non quand est ce
que j'ai essayé tout ça pendant les
départementales et les régionales j'ai
proposé que nous appelions l'opposition
de gauche que nous ayons d'un label
comment tout ça a été refusé
et maintenant sept mois avant l'élection
on serait là commence et je ne sais
quelle obscure trop tard mais c'est pas
moi qui le dit mais c'est la conclusion
que vous en tirer la conclusion que j'en
tire et que je suis candidat disponible
à tout moment à parler avec ceux qui
veulent parler avec moi mais que l'effet
m'ayant donné
je demande qu'on considère que ce que je
fais aussi un intérêt et votre
candidature est irrévocable évidemment
ma candidature ça va de soi mais vous ne
payez pas une plate forme législative
par exemple qui réunirait les
communistes et écologistes vous même
nous verrons la plateforme les
législatives c'est l'année prochaine
nous sommes pour moi l'élection
présidentielle élections législatives
c'est la même chose il faut construire
une majorité populaire sur des objectifs
et avec une candidature c'est ce que
j'essaye de valeur votre message clair
au parti communiste nos amis partenaires
ils sont toujours amis d'amis tous les
jours nos amis bien mais on avait un
accord stratégique il a cru qu'il
pouvait faire une primaire avec accor a
compris maintenant il s'en débrouille on
a compris il s'en débrouille merci
beaucoup
stéphanie est maintenant c'est mickaël à
metz depuis x ena qui arrive dans la
troisième partie de l'épreuve de vérité
avec jean luc mélenchon
bonsoir alors la question elle va être
posée par quelqu'un qui vous n'aviez pas
envie de répondre tout à l'heure mais on
va quand même l'écouter c'est jean marie
le guen sur vos pauses intentions
réelles en écoute non seulement
mélenchon a été depuis de façon
régulière contre est essentiellement
qu'on en parle de la social-démocratie
et le parti socialiste
mais ce qui est en train de se passer
c'est aussi des évolutions moi je me
demande si on ne prépare pas à vote
révolutionnaire de ce côté ça vous
suggérer que jean luc mélenchon de faire
battre françois hollande ça combien ça
peut aller plus loin bon vous allez
arriver à aller plus loin de faire et ça
veut aller plus loin
la théorie du chaos il la portait et je
veux me pose la question de savoir s'il
n'est pas un des tenants de la théorie
du chaos est trop drôle
la théorie du chaos dit le docteur le
guen il paraît qu'il est docteur la
théorie du carreau il porte la théorie
de la théorie du chaos c'est une théorie
de mathématiques ça rien à voir avec moi
j'ai écrit un livre en 1990 qui
s'appelait à la conquête du chaos dans
lequel j'ai essayé de transposer ce que
j'avais croyez avoir compris de la
théorie du chaos dans le matérialisme
historique donc c'est grotesque
ils essayent de vous dire mes hanches ou
et pour le chaos mais a joué pour le
chaos de 8
venez vite vous réfugier auprès de le
ghana après il ya un point sur lequel il
a raison quand il avait su dire pardon
de vote révolutionnaire non je ne
comprends même pas ce que ça veut dire
cher monsieur ben en 1981 par exemple
des communistes avait appelé à voter
contre françois mitterrand avant le
premier tour ah bon et oui ça va
forcément oui bien sûr il avait un
candidat donc les appeler à voter pour
le leur rappeler ça le vote
révolutionnaire
ah bon vous croyez que c'est ça que vous
appelez ça comment vous eu quand on est
communistes qu'on appelle à voter pour
son propre candidat c'était les
consignes secrètes souvenez-nous par
seconde ou anti le secret c'est parce qu
restée publiquement on parle plutôt
effectivement de quoi d'une perspective
de voter pour faire barrage au candidat
de la gauche à faire c'est ça le chaos
alors soyons sérieux que des communistes
appellent à voter pour leurs propres
candidats me paraît être normal donc
c'est pas le sujet
moi je ne suis pas communiste et je ne
suis donc pas concerné par cette affaire
maintenant il dit jean luc mélenchon a
toujours été contre la social-démocratie
banon n'a pas toujours été contre la
social démocratie
j'ai été contre la social démocratie à
partir du moment où elle est devenue
cette organisation internationale qui
dans la moitié des gouvernements
d'europe cogéré avec la droite et c'est
le cas notamment en allemagne
n'est ce pas et en france elle se charge
elle-même de tout le travail
mais commençons on parle de la
social-démocratie ya jamais eu de social
démocratie en france
n'est ce pas la différence donc c'est
pas de la social démocratie non c'est du
libéralisme matinée de discours de
gauche mais c'est de ce n'est pas ça n'a
rien à voir avec la social démocratie
je vais vous expliquer ce qu'est la
social démocratie c'est un accord entre
le parti de gauche dominants et les
syndicats d'ouvriers pour négocier avec
le patronat des avantages pour les
travailleurs ça se passe comme ça
c'est là que c'était la tradition de
toute l'europe du nord jusqu'à ce que la
social-démocratie de toute l'europe du
nord se mettent à gouverner avec la
droite et en définitive avec le patronat
bien donc en france expliqué me voir ce
qui est social démocrate dans la loi
elle conneries non s'est excusé en
faveur du patronat
non mais je vous dis je vous résume donc
je suis contre cette orientation là de
même il dit est contre le ps
en effet depuis le début du quinquennat
de monsieur françois hollande
j'explique ce qui va se passer et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui s'est passé j'avais
expliqué que la politique de l'offre ne
conduiraient à rien car une gabegie
d'argent public en pour permettre à des
gens soi disant d'investir ce qu'ils
n'ont pas fait ils n'ont pas investi
l'argent qu'ils ont ramassé grâce au cic
donc pour l'instant je ne suis coupable
que d'une chose avoir eu raison
françois hollande toujours dans ce livre
dont on a déjà parlé tout à l'heure dit
je vais le lire en force à mahler
intérêts d'un appareil de scores
oscillant ce que n'avait rien d'autre à
faire cet homme que de discuter pendant
des jours et des heures avec des
journalistes
ça je sais pas il nous dit que si jamais
en cas de 2e tour il avait un choix à
faire entre nicolas sarkozy et marine le
pen il appellerait à voter nicolas
sarkozy
feriez-vous la même chose écoutez
ci-haut deuxième tour il y avait à
choisir entre le père noël et péter
repent je crois que je voterai pour le
père noël
ça vous va c
non mais je veux dire tout le monde y va
de son petit pronostic ah bon parce
qu'ils imaginent alors maintenant il
suffit pas de régler les problèmes réels
vous rendez compte dans quoi on est là
on est dans la politique fiction en
permanence à vous donne quand même nom
mais ce sont des choses et quand on
parle plus du réel on parle plus des
confrontations réel on parle des
suppositions des uns et des autres qui
sont des manipulations
ça vous donne des grandes enquêtes pour
dire il ya des gens de gauche qui
veulent voter au premier tour de la
primaire de droite pour aider monsieur
juppé qui est aussi à droite que
monsieur sarkozy et qui lui a été
condamné parce que monsieur sarkozy est
à droite et qu'il pourrait être condamné
tout ça dégouline de cynisme de manque
d'honnêteté de tricherie partout tout le
temps à tout endroit
vous comprenez pourquoi des gens comme
moi se sentent tellement à l'aise dans
leurs baskets
moi c'est ça j'ai un programme qui est
des amis et on se bat pour convaincre
une majorité c'est la seule chose
honnête qu'on peut faire dans une
démocratie monsieur mélenchon questions
qui pourraient également se poser terme
de gauche et là c'est quand même du fond
est ce que vous êtes vraiment
irréconciliable avec la gauche la gauche
qui gouverne caisse cool et je vous dise
irréconciliables d'abord je suis de
gauche mais s'il vous plaît faites
attention à ce que vous dites parce que
la gauche les gens comprennent que je
suis avec hollande
donc c'est pour ça que je parle
d'opposition entre donc il n'est pas
d'un mouvement mais bien sûr que l'on
qui n'est pas de gauche
il suffit pas de dire je suis de gauche
il faut encore le prouver enfin
d'écouter jusqu'à présent le parti
socialiste ça reste à gauche
mais écoutez en quoi tous ces gens là
font tilt une politique de gauche je
vous supplie de me le dire non quand on
a fait la loi et conneries comme il le
comme ils l'ont fait quand on s'aligne
sur les états unis d'amérique
quand on laisse un pays avec 9 millions
de pauvres et un nombre de millionnaires
comme il n'y en a jamais eu
quand on a le record d'europe de
distribution des dividendes par les
grandes entreprises on peut pas dire si
une politique de gauche enfin écoutez
quand les gens se voient rogner leurs
droits sociaux ou pouvait pas appeler ça
une politique de gauche
donc est-ce que nous sommes
irréconciliables je suis réconciliables
avec ceux qui pratiquent cette politique
et tous les autres sont bienvenu
bienvenus et d'ailleurs on fera de la
politique je pense ensemble mais pas
seulement euh pardon de vous dire ça
souvent vous sous-estimez cet aspect il
ya plein de gens de droite aussi qu'ils
sont complètement paumé vous avez plein
de petits artisans commerçants petites
entreprises ou moyenne
qu'ils se disent qu'ils trouvent plus
intéressant ce que je raconte que les
feuillus ultralibérale de monsieur juppé
de monsieur sarkozy ou de monsieur
hollande et vous serez surpris par les
innombrables glissement qui vont se
produire de gens qui peuvent former une
majorité pour construire ce pays sur
d'autres bases alors on va vous suivre
dans la suite de votre candidature
revient dans panique bien sûr et vous
reviendrez nous voir parler du choix de
la soumission c'est ce livre un
entretien sorti récemment au seuil merci
beaucoup mais gagne merci jean luc
mélenchon merci à tous bon soir à la
semaine prochaine
bon un pote